[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: The Charles Bridge
in Prague, Czech Republic,
is one of the more
heavily trafficked tourist
destinations in central Europe.
Each year countless visitors
walk across the bridge,
take pictures of the ornate
statues lining the causeway,
and move on.
But this picture is
a little different.
It's a photo that tells
the story of Prague's
tumultuous history through
the eyes of one man for whom
that history was
very real, and it's
a photo 44 years in the taking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the man in question.
ROMAN BOED: Hello.
My name is Roman Boed.
I'm an international lawyer
and an amateur photographer
living in the Netherlands.
I was born in the predecessor
to the Czech Republic,
Czechoslovakia,
during communism.
When I was 14, I escaped
with a part of my family,
becoming a refugee and
leaving the rest of my family
and my friends behind.
INTERVIEWER: Roman
fled his home country
and its oppressive
communist government.
There had been a few attempts to
push back against that regime.
The Prague Spring in
1968 saw a new leader
trying to democratize
the government
and give the people
more personal freedom,
but that was quickly stamped out
when the Soviet Union enacted
the Brezhnev Doctrine,
which gave them the right
to intervene in any
Eastern Bloc country
with capitalist sympathies.
The Soviets and their allies
launched a bloody invasion.
Times were dark, and Roman's
family felt the strain.
ROMAN BOED: I left
Czechoslovakia in 1979.
My father, who traveled
abroad as part of his work
as an engineer, was increasingly
pressured by the secret police
to collaborate with
them, to report
what he had seen in the West,
and with whom he met and spoke.
He knew that refusing
collaboration
would set the regime
against him and his family,
so he decided to escape.
He didn't tell me
all this until we
were on our way in
neighboring Hungary.
There he explained
to me his decision
and gave me the choice to
return to Czechoslovakia alone
to join my mother and brother
or continue as refugee with him
and my sister.
INTERVIEWER: Roman
continued with his father
and found refuge at the Austrian
consulate in Yugoslavia,
but he didn't forget
about his home.
As a refugee, he kept a close
watch on Czechoslovakia,
waiting for something
good to happen.
And 18 years later while he
was living in Chicago, it did.
ROMAN BOED: You can imagine how
transfixed I was by the news
when I started to hear
about demonstrations
against the communist
regime in the fall of 1989.
INTERVIEWER: This was
the Velvet Revolution,
which started as a small
peaceful student protest
but soon became violent at
the hands of the police, which
in turn fueled outrage.
A half a million people
joined the movement.
A week later, 75% of the country
went on a general strike,
and the communist regime was
finally forced to step down.
ROMAN BOED: I returned
for the first time
13 years later with
my fiance Molly
after the fall of
the communist regime.
It was the first time I saw my
mother and my brother again.
INTERVIEWER: And for Roman,
that homecoming meant a return
to the Charles Bridge too.
ROMAN BOED: Since then, Molly
and I and our three sons
return to the Czech
Republic often,
always visiting
Prague and always
making it a point to
visit the bridge, which
seems like the center
of the whole country.
The fog made the
streets look and feel
monochrome, just the way
Prague lives in my mind
and the way I had imagined it
all those years I could not
visit.
INTERVIEWER: Of course,
the spirit of protest
is very much alive today.
It just looks a
little different.
Check out this next video
on protest in London
that may or may not be
over a bowl of cereal.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK] So now imagine
walking down a street at night
in one of the most
vibrant city in the world,
only to find it's eerily quiet.
There are no lights on in the
houses because, well, nobody
is home.
[END PLAYBACK]
INTERVIEWER: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]